All right, let's do another one of these propaganda
disinformation breakdowns where we look at
it,
blame and explain why it is deceptive yet
tricky and why it will often convince a lot
of people into just pour unfounded conclusions.
Donald Trump is under fire for his recent
pardons and clemency grants that he issued,
including to people like Bernie Kerik, uh,
the former Illinois governor rod Blagojevich
and others, and Donald Trump jr the president's
son recently tweeted, quote, Dems are mad
at Trump for abusing his pardon power total
presidential presidential pardons sentence.
Commutations and then it lists Jimmy Carter
had 566 and Reagan had four Oh six.
You know, it says Obama had 1,927 and that
Trump has only done 26 pardons and commutations
and Donald Trump jr goes on to say, please
by all means, educate me on abuse of power.
So you look at this and many Trump is tab
and they retweet it and they love it.
And they say, look, look, look, there can't
be anything wrong with Trump's pardons because
he's done 26.
And all these other presidents did way more.
Um, uh, that's where you have to say, wait,
wait a second here.
Let's apply some critical thinking.
First of all, let's take on the quantity argument.
Donald Trump has only pardoned 26 people right
now.
He's only, uh, in the middle of his first
term.
Presidents tend to issue pardons, not just
at the end of their terms, but at the end
of their presidencies.
So when you look at totals, many presidents
got the vast majority of their pardons and
Cremins clemency grants in at the very end
of their respective presidencies.
And until we see what Donald Trump does in
his last days or his last hours at the oval
office, the comparison is not relevant.
Number two, some of these numbers are very
deceptive.
So Barack Obama, the number is 1,927 to Donald
Trump's 26.
Well, in reality, Barack Obama pardoned 212
people.
And then he commuted about 1700 sentences.
When you look at those commutations that Barack
Obama did, a ton of them are drug offenders
that Donald Trump has also previously said
shouldn't be in prison and that he wants to
go ahead and deal with uh, on.
Uh, in July of 2015, Obama commuted 46 drug
sentences.
Um, in June of 2016, Obama did another 42
drug sentence commutations in December of
2016 during the Trump transition period, another
80, roughly, um, a few days before leaving
office, another 64 on his last day in office,
another 330.
So not only can you not look at these numbers
until a presidency is over.
Number one, the vast majority of the commutations
from Barack Obama, which Don jr is apparently
complaining about, are very similar to when
Donald Trump himself pardoned Alice Johnson
after Kim Kardashians lobbied him to do it.
Alice Johnson had spent 21 years behind bars
for a nonviolent drug offense.
If pardoning people for nonviolent drug offense
sentences is good according to Trump, Don
jr can't also say Obama's bad for doing the
exact same thing.
Trump here is pardoning corrupt criminals.
Trump is laying the groundwork to pardon more
of his own cronies.
Trump is normalizing corruption and setting
himself up to, pardon Roger Stone and or Michael
Flynn and whoever else.
Obama had nothing to gain personally by commuting
the sentences of drug offenders when he was
on his way out of office other than fighting
the failed war on drugs in some small way.
Trump has plenty to gain by normalizing corruption
when he's planning to use that pardon power
presumably to get his own friends and cronies
out of prison.
So do not fall for these bogus arguments.
That sound good.
Don jr does them on Twitter a lot.
There's a guy who, uh, whose name is Charlie
Kirk, who's part of a right wing, mostly like
college centered group called turning point
USA.
You see these tweets and because they are
so crafted to appear to be something they
are not, it looks like wow.
Checkmate liberals.
We, we can't even argue with that.
Obama 1900 and Trump only 26 no, you've got
to look at the details.
You have to understand what's not being said.
You have to understand the hypocrisy and the
double standards and the reality of these
things to actually understand them and you've
got to give them credit.
They are really good at bamboozling.
A lot of the people that support Donald Trump,
part of it is they're bamboozled liberal people.
A part of it is they are actually pretty good
at it and we've, we've got to do what we can
to try to Pierce
the
echo chamber.
Okay.
So, um,